The American Civil War ended almost a century
and a half ago (April 9th, 1865) with the
surrender of the Confederate forces at the
Appomattox Court House in Northern Virginia.
About 54 years ago, in December 1959, the
last reported surviving veteran of the Civil
War, Walter Washington Williams, passed away
in Houston, Texas at the reported age of 117.
President Dwight Eisenhower declared it a
national day of mourning and gave him an honorary
rank.
Congress recognized his passing on the floor.
Reporters, writers, and well-wishers all came
to Houston to pay respects to the man who
was America’s last direct living link to
the war that divided the United States for
a time.
Of course, this all may have been a lie.
According to the official history, Walter
Williams was born 1842 in Itawamba County,
Mississippi and served under General John
Bell Hood beginning in 1864.
He was a forgemaster, meaning he was in charge
of finding food and figuring out how to go
about transporting it.
After the war, in 1870, he moved to Texas
where he settled on a 20 acre farm in Eaton
(East Texas – about 100 miles from Austin).
That’s where he remained, mostly unknown,
until the late 1940s immediately following
World War II, when reporters and historians
began to seek out these last remaining survivors
of the Civil War.
Williams became a local celebrity.
He was invited to fancy dinners, given special
awards, and called by honorary titles like
“Trooper Williams”, “Honorable Colonel”,
and even “Five Star General Walter Washington
Williams.”
When interviewed by the Dallas Morning News
about how he had managed to live to such an
old age, Walter responded:
“I never et much.
I get up for breakfast, turn around for dinner,
and go to bed for supper.
When I was riding up the Chisholm Trail the
range cooks sort of held it against me because
I was a light-eating man.
I’ve always drunk lots of coffee, chewed
plenty of tobacco, and haven’t tried to
avoid any of this good Texas weather.”
On September 4, 1959, months before Williams’
death and as his hometown of Houston geared
up for Mr. Williams’ 117th birthday party,
a reporter for Scripps-Howard by the name
of Lowell Bridwell wrote a damaging exposé
potentially debunking the “Walter Washington
Williams myth.”
In it, he called Williams “an enfeebled
old man” who was a “Confederate veteran
only in his memory-clouded mind.”
Bidwell had done some digging and found not
“a single scrap” of evidence that Williams
even served in the military, much less being
the very old age of 117, like he claimed.
According to the 1860 census, Williams was
listed as five years old, meaning he was born
in 1854 and would have been only nine years
old in 1864, seemingly too young to have fought
in the Civil War.
Moreover, according to Bridwell’s reporting,
the National Archives does not list a Walter
W., a Walter G., or even a Walter L. Williams
from Texas or Mississippi as ever having served
in the Confederate Army.
Newspapers across the country picked up on
the Bridwell story and began printing their
own stories with headlines like this one from
the The Daytona Beach Journal, “Walter Williams:
Last Civil War Veteran or Hazy Memory?”
Defenders of Walter claimed that records from
that time had a reputation for being spotty.
During the last year of the war, with the
Confederate army losing and in sad shape,
they didn’t keep particularly meticulous
records of who was serving within their ranks
and even the records that did exist often
had errors, such as incorrect birth dates.
In addition, an archive in Jackson, Mississippi
lists a “Walter W. Williams” as a Private
in Company O, 5th Mississippi Cavalry.
Despite the controversy, when Walter Williams
Washington passed away in December 1959, he
was hailed across the nation as the last surviving
veteran of the Civil War.
He was laid to rest at Mount Pleasant Church
cemetery in Robertson County (near Eaton),
Texas.
His grave is now marked by an interpretive
sign, placed there by the Texas Civil War
Centennial Commission in 1963.
On the sign, it reads:
“Reputed to have been the last surviving
soldier of the Civil War…he had lived very
quietly until in extreme old age he gained
fame as one of the very few remaining veterans.
After the nation lost all other men who had
fought in the Civil War, he was given honorary
rank of General by President Dwight D. Eisenhower.
When Gen. Williams died in Houston at home
of a daughter, President Eisenhower proclaimed
a period of national mourning.”
So was Williams really the last?
It’s somewhat unclear, though most historians
today think probably not for the aforementioned
reasons.
If he wasn’t the last, that honor goes to
Albert Woolson, who passed away three years
before Williams in 1956 and is considered
within the academic community to be the last
authenticated survivor of the Civil War.
Woolson was a Union drummer boy from Minnesota
who enlisted in 1864 after his father passed
away from a severe leg wound while also fighting
for the Union.
Bonus Facts:
• Lowell Bridwell, the reporter for Scripps-Howard
who wrote the expose on Walter Washington
Williams, had a very interesting career.
While he was a reporter, he drew the ire of
J. Edgar Hoover, who suspected him of being
a communist.
Bridwell’s brother worked for the FBI at
the time and was given the assignment to spy
on his brother.
When he refused, he was forced to quit the
FBI.
Lowell went on to work in the Department of
Commerce and then in the Department of Transportation
during the Kennedy administration.
He eventually rose through the ranks and became
the director of the Federal Highway Administration
during the Johnson administration, directing
during a time of immense highway growth in
the United States.
• Walter Williams was married twice, the
second time for over 65 years.
Because of this, he had a very large family,
rumored to have had over 200 descendants when
he died.
• General John Bell Hood, the man Williams
reportedly served under, was known as a very
aggressive and reckless General.
Some historians think his massive frontal
assault at the Battle of Franklin was such
a big disaster for the Confederate army that
it lost the war for them.
During the Battle of Gettysburg, Hood (not
yet a General) was so severely wounded that
his left arm became useless for the rest of
this life.